monica bellucci
frédéric schoendoerffer le réalisateur
du film le fils de pierre schoendoerffer
voilà bonsoir conclusion monica monica
frédéric oui bien sûr monica bonsoir
alors j'ai lu dans une interview que
votre couleur préférée c'était le noir
donc je me suis habillé en noir
uniquement pour vous ce soir c'est la
première fois les chalets que ça vous
ferait plaisir et que ça vous ça vous
toucherez frédéric bonsoir donc comme je
le dis vous êtes le fils de pierre
schoendoerffer fameux réalisateur et
écrivain qui a fait le crabe tambour la
317e section et vous sortez votre
deuxième film après scènes de crime en
1999 ça s'appelle agent secret ça sort
le 31 mars avec monica bellucci re
bonsoir je ne vais pas arrêter de vous
dire bonsoir et vous regarde avec des
yeux énamourés ce soir donc voilà
vincent cassel jma qui s'est achevé hier
vincent cassel tu vois que vincent
cassel
vincent cassel
ils vous font des prix les deux qu'on
vous les prenez
cassel bellucci ça coûte moins cher les
prendre voilà oui oui absolument non non
non pas du tout d abord c'est pas moins
sert andré dussollier qui jouait déjà
dans scènes de crime comme charles
berling d'ailleurs qui est dans ce film
là et qui était déjà dans scènes de
crime il ya aussi bruno todeschini
gabrielle lazure et ludovic
schoendoerffer travaille en famille voix
oui c'est votre frère absolument mon
petit frère co scénariste et acteur
voilà et puis aussi vos enfants qui
jouent dans le film non absolument les
deux petits-enfants c'est mes enfants
car monica et la visiteurs voilà pas mal
vous êtes formidable bonne figure voilà
alors agent secret donc c'est un polar
un film de genre qui montre le quotidien
des agents secrets comme vous aviez
montrer le le quotidien des flics dans
scènes de crime
c'est plus un vécu ordinaire que très
spectaculaire frédéric non moi je pense
que c'est quand même un film d'action
pour adultes enfin pour moi c'est comme
ça que je le vois je pense qu'il ya
quand même des scènes assez assez
spectaculaire on est dans les airs on
est sous l'eau il ya quelques cascades
mais effectivement c'est plutôt l'aspect
humain de ces personnages qui
m'intéresse c'est à dire des personnages
au bord du précipice qu'ils sont des
gens comme nous et de les voir très très
proche et et voir un peu comment se
l'être humain se comporte à ce moment là
voilà c'est un peu ça l'idée lorsqu'on
découvre dans le film parce que c'est la
réalité quoi c'est qu'en fait les agents
secrets sont toujours entre la légalité
et l'illégalité et ils commettent au nom
de la loi des actes illégaux en fait
c'est ça et
c'est le principe un peu des services
secrets c'est un principe mais là quand
c'est monica qui se retrouve dans cette
situation évidemment on s'y intéresse on
s'y attache c'est normal comment ça va
très bien vous êtes bien là habsheim
langue bien vous êtes magnifique
vraiment
le plus bas c'est simple ça commence
comme le rainbow warrior un monica c'est
un petit peu dominique prieur vincent
c'est un peu à la maaf art l'effet peau
d'orange voilà les faux époux tu ranges
la e200 fond le couple exactement
laurent donc ils ont comme mission de
faire sauter un bateau à casablanca
s'est voulue casablanca les espions
casablanca comme ça c'est une situation
frédéric c'est assez marrant en fait au
départ je devais tourner en turquie et à
cause de la guerre en irak
les assurances couvraient plus donc on
s'est retourné au milieu du tournage à
casablanca et je suis assez content en
fait parce que c'est une très très belle
ville c'est un peu le new york du
maghreb est donc finalement c'est pas
mal alors voilà au début donc tout va
bien ils font sauter ce bateau ça on
peut le dire mais le problème est là je
raconterai pas la suite évidemment c'est
quand monica vous rentrer en suisse
après le sabotage de ce bateau qui
transporte des armes vous fait arrêté à
la douane avec 150 grammes d'héroïne et
il faut dire que vous aviez un petit peu
annoncé la direction votre intention de
partir voilà j'en dis pas plus mais
c'est un vrai thriller c'est à partir de
là bon au début il ya l'action
effectivement et puis à partir de là on
est complètement aux abois c'est par le
sort de monica de monique
de ces très protégé ce soir voilà vous
êtes en sécurité lorsque vous avez
rarement été rapport au film se sent
plus
rarement été aussi en sécurité que ce
soit vincent m'a dit tu t'occupes d'elle
moi vous savez je suis un garçon fidèle
loyal et bien moi je la supporte plus le
voilà alors monica vous allez faire un
truc vous avez regardé votre caméra s'il
vous plaît et vous dites simplement
magnéto serge faisant voler votre tout
non
celle qui a le rouge et vous dites
magnéto serge
la mission qu'il réunit aujourd'hui pour
nom de code genus
de nos agents à genève travaillent déjà
sur cette affaire
[Musique]
sous vaste soit-il
attention
j'en ai marre de tout ça n'est pas mes
parents mes amis toute façon je n'ai pas
mais nous suivre s'ils libèrent des amis
tout raté vrai qu'ils ne sont pas dans
la maison
mais des noirs et rouges arrête jamais
voulu casser les rangs
c'est le refus de collaborer on me
demande pas de collaborer on lui demande
d' obéir jeu direct c'est toi qui a
plongé les uns adroit que dans ma valise
c'est la maison
tu connais la loi le secret
s'agit pas d'émotions ici il s'agit
d'affaires
[Musique]
tu passes ta nea mais les autres
matériels de 10 pouces ou plus
il fera pas de venir je suis français
ce qui peut t'arriver à ceux qui
transgressent les règles
nous ne sais pas
moi aussi je te demande si ce que je
fais un sens une chose dont je suis sûr
n'aurait pas voulu vivre autrement rien
au monde
agent secret de frédéric schoendoerffer
avec vincent cassel et monica bellucci
qui ne l'indiqué ce soir car de bonnes
clientes à ça c'est génial grâce à sa
monica vous revenez quand vous voulez ah
bon même si vous n'avez pas de films à
vendre vous passez finira comme ça quand
je comme ça quand vous les 6,1 soit vous
savez pas quoi faire non mais c'est vrai
que vous êtes dans ce film complètement
normal qu avec des jeans des baskets les
cheveux coupés courts pas très bien
coupé en plus donc c'est vraiment
difficile pour vous de faire ça ne
s'était pas difficile à c'était
justement intéressant d'échanger le
personnage parce que c'est vrai que moi
même si je fais des rôles des rôles
forts on partait toujours
du fait que les personnages jamais
incertain physique et là c'est
complètement différent je vais pas sur
les séductions enfin moins que
d'habitude disons beaucoup moins que
d'habitude c'est pas les chars mais
c'est pas la séduction justement mais
c'est une femme avec un physique banal
mais qui a un qui a une démarche
exceptionnelle
alors les lois du fantasme à la quand
même vous êtes mais c'est fait exprès et
frédéric faudrait qu'ils aient manière
détournée qui est assez documentariste
chez un chirurgien c'est scalpel a
montré tous tes traits essentiels du
coup même les jeux qu'ils veulent et ses
actes or c'est justement sur la retenue
c'est une certaine pudeur en m dans le
jeu je crois qui malgré ça quand même
attention pas si tout à fait alors voilà
donc c'est une 28e film avec vincent
cassel c'est le premier où il se passe
rien entre vous vous êtes un faux couple
pour devrait donc il ya quelque chose
mais voilà il n'y a pas de ya pas de
conclusions et vous dites souvent quand
on vous pose la question mais travailler
avec vincent ça nous permet de nous voir
davantage voilà donc c'est vous joignez
l'utile à l'agréable
il est où là il est au brésil
il a paris c'est paris non mais c'est
vrai que nous en voyage énormément on
travaille pas tout le temps ensemble et
de céret voir sur les plateaux c'est
super aussi parce que moi quand je dis
toujours en facilement jeunes acteurs
quand je joue avec lui je ne sais pas la
personne que je connais dans la vie et
du coup je dois être à l'auteur avec ces
sites vous étonnez l'un l'autre quand
vous est important de se reprendre j'ai
quoi c'est important de se surprendre de
la ville allait travail je crois c'est
le secret de détour de l'amitié de
l'amour c'est plus pour se surprendre
que pour ceux ci ont veillé finalement
non c'est surveillé je crois que c'est
quelque chose d'horrible ne vous promet
pas pourquoi tu sais où il est quand il
tourne avec toi oh vous savez on peut
être elle a la tête ailleurs voilà voilà
mais lui non c'est vrai que monique a
assuré qu'il est souvent au brésil vous
vous êtes basé à londres c'est vrai que
c'est pas c'est pas toujours facile vous
avez de longue séparation on se connaît
on était déjà des acteurs et voilà une
autre vieille pas continuer comme ça et
même pire parce que c'est vrai que l'on
travaille de plus en plus et je crois
que c'est l'avis des acteurs et je crois
pas qu'il y à une logique pour que une
couple marche il n'y a pas une loi et
moi je pense toujours que chaque jour en
plus qui fait si que l'histoire continue
à être jouée miracle vous faites pas des
grands plans sur la comète vide chaque
jour est un jour de gagné finalement
vous êtes très réaliste mais oui parce
que on ne peut pas décider pour les
autres on change on évolue voilà alors
vous aider fois de longues séparations
parce qu'une fois vous êtes séparés 5
tout content que tout ait des
séparations et
je suis content mais je suis content et
vicieux il est méchant
non mais c'est vrai une fois vous êtes
séparés pendant cinq mois signe a le
malheur des autres souvenirs sauf deux
petites de petite interruption mais
salue tout
croyant bien sûr sur vous je connais
tous non mais cinq mois cinq mois c'est
long quand maintenant comment c'est long
mais on sait il m'a quand même hein je
les rejoins il va rejoindre deux fois 5
2 fois pour combien des jours
non c'est pas ça maintenant c'est des
courtes des coucous retrouvailles vous
savez vous savez bien oui mais c'est pas
c'est pas tout les années comme ça à
l'essence puis la 12e année où c'est
comme ça c'est pas tout le temps comme
ça mais ça veut dire que ça marche
comment nous donnez moi ma femme
n'habite pas avec moi et ça marche de
ses 20 ans baby ton nom
vous êtes jaloux ce nom un peu sourire
agences italiennes
si vous trompez ce que vous ne tuez par
exemple voilà une question à oui je
pourrais déjà aller
pourriez le tuer je prédis
j'aime les femmes qui sont capables de
tuer par un moment il n'y a plus y en a
plus je n'ai pas peur qui tombe amoureux
d'une partenaire dans ce jeu par mais
c'est normal et s'est trouvé avec de
très belles femmes sur les plateaux ont
même dehors du plateau je crois que
ça fait partie du jury ce nom vous dit
vous êtes acteur tous les deux donc il
peut se retrouver nu mais tendance qui
se retrouve nue dans un film est ce que
vous lui interdirait ou est ce que vous
trouvez ça bien vous réagiriez comment
je garde c'est pas des ventes s'est pas
grossi non non j'ai rien dit wang ça
veut dire qu'il a très bien joué
mais les dans son personnage qui est
enfin il est un premier temps
quand vous êtes avec lui comme ça comme
c'est un très bon comédien vous voyez
quand il vous parle s'ils jouent la
comédie ou six ouais vraiment je crois
que l'essence un comédien qui a
énormément de talent va les sens que il
peut tout faire c'est vrai que il fait
un énorme sexuelle d'un elisabeth et les
super il fait une homme de la rue dans
sur mes lèvres et unis croire on fait il
fait l'aristocrate dans le pacte des
loups l'agencé créée on y croit voilà
que l'acteur est très éclectique je
devrais pas dire ça mais là je possède
je suis objectif tout à fait mais il a
de la chance à vincent cassel parce
qu'on peut être juste une telle star une
telle icône que je suis sûr que les mac
os x vous draguer je suis sûr que vous
leur fait peur aux mac non
[Musique]
j'ai peur non non je crois pas non non
vous croyez que je pars avec moi je suis
je sais pas du tout d'argent heureuse je
suis assez douces
espèce de ds intouchable à laquelle en
hausse que demander des autographes
non je ne sais pas je sais pas l'image
que je projette je convainque je ne
crois pas qu'on sait ce qu'on projette
moi je fais mon métier c'est vrai que
peut-être que l'image glacée de photo de
couverture paie donne une image qui peut
être plus froide mais mais moi je ne
crois pas l'être froide à la vie alors
vous aimez en fait être une vraie femme
vous et c'est ça que je trouve
remarquable parce que vous le dites est
aujourd'hui souvent les filles les
actrices le disent pas visite à quoi bon
mettre des belles robes avec des tas de
boutons derrière s'il n'y a pas une main
virile pour les déboutonnée là vraiment
je verrais bien qui a créé sa
williams et head en canoë c'est quoi ah
c'est un jour elle vous a donné une
interview canoë vous êtes jamais dit ça
je trouve ça pas mal pourtant il a
couvert une journée c'est à dire c'est
pas mal mais ça ne changerait ce qu'il a
dit par mois ah bon
mais d'ailleurs il a raison parce que
vous dites aussi dans la série j'aime
être une femme et que les sommes soient
des hommes
c'est leur sauvagerie oh là là non c'est
dans
c'est la sauvagerie leur bestialité leur
brutalité qui fait que nous sommes
attirés par eux à la moi je sais pas ce
qu'il a rêvé ce mec
c'est une fille que j'aimais bien être
travaillée par des filles vous dites
d'ailleurs moi j'adore les films la joie
qu'elle arrivait quelque chose et jours
après la créature mais alors est ce que
pour vous quand même ça je vous l'avais
bien dit à un moment est ce que pour
vous là la peur de l'acte sexuel ne va
pas de pair avec l'érotisme oui vous
vous êtes l'âme fasciné par le tableau
de picasso la dora maar quand même aimé
le tort c'est vrai
mais c'est pas mal d'être une vraie
femme moi je trouve oui mais savait pas
dire que quand on est un homme qui est
brutal au qui est macho moi je n'aime
pas ça mais quand même énorme qu'ils
soient à tous qui respecte les femmes
en tous les cas vous êtes vous êtes une
vraie une vraie femme n'hésite pas une
intel viennent d'opérette puisque vous
êtes bien thomas may et voilà bientôt a
pas longtemps à l'automne
c'est incroyable
incroyable vous savez plus que moi c'est
que je suis étonnée je sais même le sexe
de l'enfant mais je ne dirais pas parce
que vous avez si je les fais pas on a
décidé mais disent ils avec votre public
vous faire la surprise c'est à monclar
et laurent pause bisous déjà ouais
je
m
en brasse frédérick toi ben non moi j'ai
envie que d'embrasser que monica je peux
faire comme toi fin servant d'avoir
envie d'embrasser de frédéric pour après
avoir simulé
rien d'autre toi fred 1 c'est pas du
tout c'est pas ton oscille de maintenant
affaire monica physiquement voilà bien
alors on va parler d'un autre film qui
sort aussi rapidement lassé film de mel
gibson qui s'appelle la la passion du
christ sur les écrans français le 31
mars vous jouez le rôle de marie
madeleine pour vous c'est un personnage
extraordinaire parce que vous dites que
marie-madeleine finalement le seul qui
la regarde comme un être humain c'est
jésus mais c'est ça qui vous a attiré
dans le personnage ce qui m'attire et ce
justement l'effet que c'est une femme
faible comme comme électriquement du
coup c'est une femme qui pêche comme moi
comme vous je crois sans doute comme
tout le monde et du coup elle ne
rappelle l'état une honte c'est pour ça
que j'étais touché par super six
personnages j'avais envie de l'incarner
à l'écran et voilà quand j'ai rencontré
ma gibson
on se trouvait et voilà et je me suis
retrouvé dans ce film c'était une belle
expérience jeter
à rome j'étais amateur sud et l'italie
et c'est vrai que c'est un film mary
très violent j'hésite à côté
irréversible c'est bon be alors que vous
savez tout c'est vrai je dis ça c'est
vrai je crois que c'est un film très
violent mais comment je dis toujours je
crois que la vie de jésus est violente
et du coup les films ne pouvait pas être
différent vous allez faire la promotion
de ce film
je fais je ne suis pas les états unis
parce que justement que vous savez je
t'aime bébé et du coup je voulais pas je
sais plus encore
c'est le deuxième le savoir j'ai fait la
promo pour l'agencé crème alors pour
faire le film la passion du christ
devait refuser un gros film américain
vouliez vraiment faire le rôle mais ça
valait film de mel gibson est vraiment
comme un petit film à petit budget comme
indépendant pour moi c'était un film
d'auteur de mes disques des mains gibson
en effet personne croyez ce film ha et
nous agirons une dizaine - les cas il
faut pas les faire croûte vraiment ça le
film juste que va créer de polémique
mais je crois pas que les filles vont
voir les jambes on voit le film est un
échec tout ce qui arrive aux basses et
ses films vraiment personne n'y croyait
plus alors pour vous en faites la
violence cas dans ce film c'est la
violence inhérente à l'être humain et
vous dites quand vous avez vu le
pianiste de polanski
j'ai eu honte de faire partie du genre
humain donc en fait ce film la passion
du christ ne fait que traduire cette
violence qui nous appartient à tous moi
je crois que quand on sort du film
justement ce qu'on sent c'est qu'est-ce
qu'il ya qui va pas avec l'être humain
c'est pourquoi l'homme depuis des milan
a pas changé pourquoi l'homme se
comporte comme ça avec l'homme et voilà
après bien sûr moi je suis pas quelqu'un
de croyante
comme toujours je suis agnostique du
coup je veux pas parler des choses que
je peux pas expliquer je dis pas je suis
athée parce qu'elle ait raté c'est déjà
prendre une position
je crois qu'il est trop
limité pour dire à dieu n'existe pas
alors vous dites la technologie c'est ok
il ya la télévision partout il ya le
portable mais en fait l'être humain n'a
pas beaucoup évolué depuis l'homme de
néandertal
moi je crois pas je crois qu'il est
peut-être qu'il y à quelque chose
à nous on a quand même des bêtes
peut-être qu'on fait partie justement de
la nature et la nature je crois qu déjà
à asnelles pour avoir un équilibre et
les fondée sur la violence de l'essence
qui pour exister un loup doit manger à
nyon un lien d'en manger une gazelle du
coup déjà la nature en soit il n'est pas
juste et nous on fait partie de cette
nature du coup on a cette violence en
nous et c'est pour ça aussi que moi
j'aime bien regarder ce qu'il ya
derrière
la façade ce qui a derrière elle à
masquer qu'on a nous pour nous protéger
c'est pour cela que j'ai envie de faire
les films comme agent secret par exemple
au défilement ou je dois chercher
les côtés noir d'elektrim ans est agent
secret vous n'êtes pas dans vos dans vos
repères habituels je crois que
en effet ce que ce passé qui en
vieillissant on mûrit et
peut-être moi je suis en train
d'acquérir plus de sécurité du coup sûr
moi on me propose de rôles comment
proposer pas avant et c'est vrai que je
dois dire qu'ils construiraient que
chandler pharma proposer son film
j'étais très flatté qu'ils avaient pensé
à moi pour un rôle commencé voilà c'est
pas un rôle habituel ça vous est venu
comment
c'est pas moi qui ai eu l'idée c'est le
producteur névés oui voilà et tout de
suite éric m'a parlé de monica qui
connaissait pas ce qu'il avait produit
le doberman six ou sept ans avant j'ai
rencontré dans un petit café à côté de
chez elle et je veux dire quand on
diminue d'un quart d'heure
en dix minutes un quart d'heure j'ai été
assez
comment dire assez fasciné par l'actrice
quoi et le côté prêt prêt à tout pour
jouer c'est à dire le côté non mais le
côté très une actrice qui peut aller
dans toutes les directions c'est à dire
un moment donné je vais proposer un rôle
peut-être un chemin peu empruntés et ça
l'a tout de suite beaucoup beaucoup
intéressé et
je vais donner le scénario trois jours
après elle m'a appelé en me disant
qu'elle faisait le film et je peux vous
dire que pour un mois je suis un jeune
réalisateur c'est mon deuxième film et
quand vous avez un coup de fil de monica
bellucci qui vous dit qu'elle va faire
le film c'est énorme que ce qui se passe
est de plus en plus vous êtes sûr de
faire le film donc je lui serai toujours
éternel éternellement reconnaissant non
mais c'est vrai je le dis voilà
côté hamas
alors monica
monica vous êtes belle intelligente
décidé je disais tout à l'heure les
hommes n'osent pas vous vous draguez
parce que vous êtes comme une icône
comme ça comme une déesse intouchable
alors vas y si quand même on va faire
une interview mode d'emploi
monica vous préférez les mecs beau gosse
les mecs intelligents les mecs comme moi
bah alors que vous êtes intelligent et
beau gosse comme vous en
plus vous êtes habillé manière pour moi
pour vous il me suis embrouillé j'ai
l'habitude de chamblanc alors qu'elle
est qu'elle est la meilleure phrase
monica pour vous abordez
pas de me dire je serai tous cas facile
votre poème préféré j'apprendrai parker
moi j'aime bien à s'il vient ce poème
comme chaque mois les eaux par des
italiens vous allez dire dites moi alors
là parlez-moi italien je vais fermer les
yeux je vais craquer complètement
juste quelques verres silvia elle est
même bien qu al akwa le terme de
l'atonie de mortal coin de bell tu as
plein air
quelle chance de faire ce métier
c'est gratuit
alors l'endroit idéal pour vous donner
un premier rendez-vous
qui imaginez que vous donnent rendez
vous puisque bon là on a un petit peu
tous les deux
alors un restaurant parce que je n'en
mange d'accord oui c'est vrai à lyon
c'est vrai vous aimez bien manger c'est
que génial cet épicurien une brigadière
le geste qui vous fait craquer chez un
homme
les gestes qui me fait craquer à
un peu les larmes aux yeux un homme qui
pleure vrai nous ça ne les sens pas tiré
et la plainte lorsque j'essaye de un
geste
je parle ça peut être
[Musique]
une caresse
même rim qui reste qu'on se ferait à soi
ça peut te fait craquer
le geste qui trahi votre trouble
ag je deviens rouge géologie jeu des
plaques partout à la wii dans ce cas
vous êtes comme ça c'est que vous êtes
troublé par l'homme qui est en fait à
côté où elle a du sens qui monte à la
dame qu'est l'alcool qui vous montre le
plus rapidement à la tête à tout parce
qu'elles ont fait je ne bois pas trop et
mélina
donc à lui être qu'elle est la ville la
plus romantique selon vous monica à
paris rome rome paris remet pas le
quartier où on a le plus de chance de
vous rencontrer
par rapport à l'aéroport bien le
compliment qu'il ne faut jamais vous
faire
j'aime tous les compliments sont jamais
assez les compliments celui qu'on vous a
jamais fait je crois que dans
l'inventaire
vous êtes impressionné par les gens qui
savent rod et qui savent quoi rothé non
ça veut dire quoi
rod et ça veut dire faire un repos tout
comme les dvd c'est après
impressionné
même les enfants sont de faire sa merci
un homme qui fait ça ça casserait tout
pour vous ça casse chacun serait tout
bon fan si on le sait on qu'on ne refera
pas qu'elle ait envie de péter
soulier charles berling gabrielle lazure
x hunter peur et brunes skinny quand un
cinéma près de chez vous le 31
j'ai passé un moment divin je suis très
heureux qu'on m'ait fait mon année là à
peu près merci beaucoup monica
j'accueille maintenant monica bellucci
et bernard campan
dk bel outil et bernard campan le
nouveau couple du cinéma français
mesdames messieurs
bonsoir
vous êtes moins d'harmonica jeu des
talons quand même pour l'italie est
assez grande
vous êtes petit bernard
alors vous êtes ici pour combien tu
m'aimes le nouveau film de bertrand
blier avec vous deux gérard depardieu
jean pierre darroussin ça sort mercredi
voilà alors bernard dans le film vous
jouez un homme qui gagne au loto et qui
décide d'épouser une prostituée qui est
interprétée par monica bellucci c'est
bien le cinéma quand même un bon côté
c'est mieux que la vie quand même
scénario 1 voilà voilà que pour moi gros
coup de bol
vous est demandé que le tournage dure
plus longtemps vous vous êtes inquiétés
non non non non non on n'a pas ça n'a
pas fait de rites ex et ensuite ça va on
a on en est resté à ce qui était écrit
malheureusement mais ça s'est très bien
passé il très très bien passé alors vous
monica après keanu reeves et bruce
willis ça fait quoi de jouer avec un un
séducteur comme si pourtant que tu poses
la comprend
moi je suis très très flatté vraiment
j'étais gâté d'ailleurs d'avoir à côté
de moi un acteur comme
il est excitant quand même il est
excitant vraiment monica dans combien tu
m'aimes vous jouez donc le rôle d'une
prostituée vous dites est les [ __ ]
comme toutes les femmes qui veulent
séduire
c'est vrai dans le sens de ce que moi je
cherchais un mois
ce que j'ai commencé du triste j'ai
utilisé aussi ça et après bien sûr à
côté de moi j'avais un des grands
maîtres du cinéma français bertrand
blier et c'est sûr qu'ils travaillaient
à la caractère pareil on apprend
énormément en tant que comédienne un peu
misogyne quand même nom d'un peu
misogyne pas du tout moi je ne trouve
pas qu'il est misogyne mais parce qu'il
a toujours écrit des rôles très forts
pour les femmes est un réalisateur qui
écrit drôle comme ça ça veut dire qu'ils
aiment les femmes tout simplement est
même mêlé rôle d'emma prostituées des
daniela c'est vrai qu'il faut situer
même temps c'est une femme très forte
très libre qui dessinent de ce qu'elle
veut et les très très très sauvage et
c'est ça qui me plaît du coup ça vaut le
féministe alors dans ce film vous n'êtes
pas une prostituée en cuissardes et en
skaï avec porte jarretelles et
ghesquière vous n'êtes pas vulgaire du
tout vous êtes habillé classique espèce
de prostituées un peu fellinienne la
maman et la [ __ ] moment les ans
alors je dis mama quand même parce que
c'était juste après l'accouchement et
quand même vous êtes bien d'enchères
c'est incroyable aujourd'hui j'aurais pu
passer ce rôle pareil parce que c'est
tout cette chère tout cette rondeur
donne quelque chose des jeunes heureux
personnage quelque part c'est comme si
elle aimait la terre entière avec ce
corps quand vous avez dit justement un
peu fellinien et je crois que ces films
ceux ci une hommage au cinéma italien
pendant tournage à laitiers entre les
prises course mais d'ailleurs j'ai
trouvé ça très très beau et très simple
pour une comédienne a dépassé à faire
tout drôle à voir les scènes d'amour
avec bernard et après voilà j'ai fait
drôle quand elles disent un sng monique
bernard bernard que ça doit faire drôle
surtout vert
ça vous a pas gêné monica de montrer
votre corps comme s'alourdit quand même
non je dois dire que j'ai même moment de
peur quand j'ai appris tout de suite
après l'accouchement parce que je savais
que trois mois après je vais commencer à
tourner je me disais je serai jamais
prête est prêt je dis je peux pas faire
autrement je suis comme ça et je crois
que voilà c'est bien aussi d'avoir le
courage de mettre en scène une femme qui
est lé contraire de des codes de la mode
d'aujourd'hui alors il faut être un
grand défi ni forme et elle elle est
l'opposé des dessins énorme dans le film
voilà alors qu'à bientôt je vais pas
tenir toutes les démarches
il joue aussi ça veut dire laissons
aussi joué un rôle d'aidant vos
mensurations normales c'est 95 c'est 60
90 et samedi je sais pas j'ai vérifié je
peux dire que j'aime aussi un petit peu
oui les pouilles beaucoup de scènes
d'amour physique tous les deux et que si
vous avez déclaré pour que ces scènes
soient bien jouer faut qu'une vraie
relation entre les deux noms comme ils
sont jaloux
mais si c'est important c'est du jeu et
c'est bien qu'il y à une intimité qu'il
y a quand même tu peux pas faire ça il
ya des acteurs avec qui tu joues bien
des acteurs avec toujours pas bien je
dois dire qu'il bernard qu'un point
c'est un partenaire un magnifique
je crois
tu as vraiment gagner au loto à l'abbé
vraiment je regarde ma place et c'est
bingo bingo
nous dit on entre vraiment dans
l'intimité de l'autre quand on joue ce
genre de scène non mais dans l'essence
que
c'est il faut même pas les scènes
d'amour qui sont difficiles à jouer
c'est plutôt faire croire à l'amour
parce que quand même sinon assez rare
présence et une représentation de la
réalité tout simplement et
c'est vrai qu'ils comptaient avec
quelqu'un avec qui tu t'entends bien et
ça c'était le cas avec bernard mais
c'est vrai que j'étais entouré de
partenaires incroyable j'étais entourée
de mecs qui étaient là pour mes soeurs
sentir bien mais protégé
et je crois qu'ils te senlis en battant
berne a arrêté que le sourire ça va bien
ça énerve tout le monde maintenant
passé qui revient bon le passé selon lui
ce traumatisme
alors y'a un côté effectivement très
très italien comme ça l'opéra les pâtes
le linge qui sèche sur le part dieu où
ils barrent ya absolument
il ya une italianité dans le film qui
fait penser effectivement à silvana
mangano à gina lollobrigida sophia loren
ça c'est trop moi tout ce que je peux
dire c'est qu'il vient sur aujourd'hui
je fais du cinéma c'est parce que cette
femme là c'est faux mais là m'ont fait
rêver bien sûr et je crois que si
bertrand blier aime le cinéma italien
voilà ici aurait pu l'attendre mais je
réfléchissais danse avec bertrand il
fonctionne à l'inspiration quoi et je
pense que je sais pas si au début du
film l'italie elle et prendre une place
aussi importante
de même que deux cordes de daniela a
pris beaucoup de place et l'italie aussi
peut-être dans l'inspiration de bertrand
a fait son chemin et les airs d'opéra
ont débarqué le film est devenu franco
italien très très très vite quoi alors
bernard
bellucci bertrand blier c'est bien pour
un accès inconnu non oui vous savez
pourquoi vous avez choisi bertrand blier
berlin jeu ça il avait vu le film de
zabou breitman mais se souvenir des
belles choses il a envie de à l'occasion
c'est une idée de l'inspirer il dit vous
avez un côté ou lb kg 1 c'est à dire un
peu français moyen oui bah voilà
monsieur tout le monde mec lambda way
sam sam va ça me convient la
quintessence du physique français alors
dans le prochain film de zabou breitman
cd charles berling dont vous tombez
amoureux oui ça va le changer
finies les vacances est moins drôle à
l'harmonica ça va bien très bien
j'ai pas vu vincent cassel depuis
blueberry
donc vient de remplacer on va faire une
interview vincent cassel
[Musique]
bonsoir vincent cassel ça me fait très
plaisir de vous recevoir comment allez
vous battre eh bien
vous avez laissé pousser vous je veux
bah oui pour un rôle plus à faire les
14es pour un rôle je suis prête à tout
les griots sylvain simplement vous
trouvez bola merci pour moi je suis pas
[ __ ] mais la boucle
et de dire et de radio c'est l'amour qui
vous rend comme ça bah oui ça se passe
bien que monica oui vous êtes content
d'avoir un enfant avec elle je suis
c'est rami ça vous plaît d'être papa
absolument faire d'autres enfants avec
elle j'espère qu'est ce que ça fait
quand on entend vous répéter toute la
journée que sa femme est la plus belle
femme du monde pense qu'on a de la
chance ouais
qu'est ce que vous aimez chez monica
vincent
oui qu'est-ce que la deux qu'est ce
qu'elle a de plus beau selon vous un
cerveau
vous êtes jaloux oui ah oui c'est normal
c'est vrai que cherche bernard campan
partout pour elle pourrait la gueule
qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus chez
elle
[Musique]
il ya d un film de monica que vous
n'avez pas aimé vincent
non même le dernier film de blier j'ai
vraiment adoré il est bien on peut dire
que c'est un bon blier ah oui
j'adorerais vraiment j'ai plongé des
dangers très les films incroyables je
crois que pour la carrière de monica
c'est très bien c'est un effet j'ai
pensé qu'ils aient vraiment je l'avais
jamais vu comme ça
est ce que vous voyez monica souvent
vincent
non pas vraiment parce qu'elle tourne le
tournage est encore en tournage à huy a
été en mongolie l' état mongolie la mer
entraîneront des tournées des coups ils
travaillent dans la lah et vincent vous
draguez toujours un peu vous quand même
bah oui
c'est normal je reste quand même énorme
c'est même sens il faut regarder les
autres femmes pour apprécier la sienne
[Musique]
vincent sérieusement ciel partez vous
feriez quoi
j'ai lavé serez libre c'est la seule
manière pour qu'elle retourne en arrière
guy mallinson vincent geisser il a
change rien il a parlé comme ça il ya
cantié moi ici connaît un sexuellement
ça se passe bien avec mme cavin sens
bien très bien très bien non vous avez
fait quoi pour la séduire vincent
j'étais juste moi même avant
c'est embêtant pour les autres
qu'est ce que vous détestez le plus chez
vous vincent
mon côté feuq et ceci ma force
notre principal défaut c'est quoi
vincent
je suis
et rois et royaumes ça se dit ça c'est
pas chez nous mais ça doit se dire
c'est très marrant est très marrant
qu'il dise ah ouais parce que moi aussi
je me sens un peu dire ou à
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup d'énergie
vattenfall yang et r'way
et arbitres n'ont pas forcément
vous avez peur qu'elle vous trompez
licka
et on a eu bernard content
mais alice et qu'elle les faire arriver
sûr de lui accorder
il ya des choses que vous aimeriez dire
harmonica vincent ce soir revient déjà
dans tous les cas merci vincent revenez
quand vous voulez je trouve super mini
ali
de toi car
mais voilà toutes les cartes étaient
comme ça je sais pas dit car il y avait
pire vous devez choisir un invité et la
brocélia que comporte
tout ce qu on pense soit seulement six
bisons ils sont dogon passer quand même
ah oui c'est moins bien que dans le film
non mais c'est assez physique il faut
payer pour voir c'est devenu une
citrouille maintenant
un arc en bout 2 michel roussin si votre
physique c'est en ce moment a fait
pschitt ah non vous êtes en pleine
félicité oui ça se voit oui oui voilà
donc à lohan
n'en ajoutaient ils ah oui il m'a dit le
pense pas
yaro en voilà et on pense maintenant à
notre grand invité d'honneur de la
semaine
[Musique]
monica bellucci bonsoir
à monica vous avez toujours c'est
incomparable accent qui nous fait
voyager
doublé mais sur des chemins
t il
tous les
il est unique et le ciel
lilicub voyage en italie en hommage à
monique akbar
alors même qu'un c'est un accent vous
avez vraiment ou fait semblant parce que
l'autre agent vous demande de garder cet
accent
je voudrais parler parfaitement j'arrive
pas même si vous êtes un peu la jane
birkin italienne
équeuter j'adore j'aime bien king merci
pour la comparaison mais voilà l'accent
est là et quand je travaille à un effet
dans un film français je vois avoir un
coach chaque fois pour que l'accent soit
l'esprit alors il ya l'accent il ya la
beauté parce que l'accent sur la beauté
ça marche pas
trop calme ça vous agace ça vous flatte
ça vous laisse indifférente
mais ça m'amuse surtout aussi parce que
je veux dire maintenant je suis une
femme adulte du coup d'être considéré
fantasme ça me fait un peu rire il vous
arrive de jouer de votre image monica
bellucci tous les jours chaque
geste une femme je vous pose la question
parce que la pression qui est exercée
sur les femmes précisément la pression
de l'image vous la ressentez vous mais
la pression je crois des images et six
sur les hommes prix garder les hommes
aujourd'hui sept ans les cheveux
font de piqûres de partout faut arrêter
par les quais des femmes mais bon sens
et ce en s'appréciant cible
[Musique]
de nombreuses fois femme la plus belle
du monde ça a commencé très jeune
mais
oh
un jour votre père vous demande pourquoi
n'allez pas jouer au square avec les
autres et vous répondez parce que tout
le monde me regarde les hommes les
filles j'ai tellement belle que quand
vous allez déjeuner au restaurant ont
fait cadeau du déjeuner ou du dîner
c'est vrai
que je parle à toutes les femmes
nous avait été remarqué très jeune on
imagine très bien votre vie dans cette
petite ville de hongrie ou en fait une
femme qui est très jolie elle est un peu
considéré comme un extraterrestre
non quand on est jolie on crée de la
curiosité mais
c'est vrai que s'il n'y a rien d'autre
la curiosité fini très vite et quand je
dis toujours c'est vrai que j'ai fait
rien d'exceptionnel je suis jolie et je
fais la comédienne du coup c'est assez
banal tout ça il n'y a pas autre chose à
côté une curiosité morbide dites vous du
simple fait d'exister
dire que ma jambe quand vous rentrez
chez vous au lieu de passer par la place
principale où faisait le tour vous parce
que tout le monde vous regardez moi je
viens d'un petit village du coup c'est
vrai que peut-être quand on est jolie on
a regardé et
j'ai toujours
et puis monica vous êtes devenue
mannequin
[Musique]
oh
j
et
et donc actrice avec l'appartement
doberman
suspicion le pacte des loups astérix et
obélix irréversible matrix la passion du
christ et diane bond 007
spectra
[Musique]
et vous revenez donc avec un film
éblouissant
un film réalisé tania kusturica dans
lequel il joue lui même ça s'appelle
rhône 2000 qui rôdent c'est une histoire
d'amour passionnée entre des gens qui ne
sont plus si jeune finalement passé à
l'histoire d'amour comment vous dites
vous un train de personnes qui ne sont
plus jeunes et que
peut-être il ça ton plus rien de la vie
parce que cette femme elle fuit
quelqu'un qui veut la tuer du coup elle
veut se marier pour changer d'identité
et lui selon lequel la guerre a perdu
toute sa famille qui était musicien
avant et on est devant une aventure
une course entre la vie et la mort et où
il y à des violences de la guerre de la
mort mais sûrement sur l'extase ans
espace pour un guerre de yougoslavie
donc lui traverse la ligne de front tous
les jours pour livrer du lait aux
soldats est une réfugiée italienne qui
débarque dans son monde et puis à l'art
de kusturica c'est à dire on est ravi de
retrouver le coup story 5 on adore avec
un côté un peu magique avec les oies
dans le bain de sang la poule qui
sautent devant le miroir les moutons qui
explosent ils magie de l'image qui est
très rare au cinéma aujourd'hui
dans les films de kusturica il ya
toujours cette dualité entre la réalité
la fantasy
et cette peut-être envie d kusturica
travers son cinéma des fous rires la
douleur de son pays qui est beau mais on
sent vraiment encore la douleur la
tristesse de la guerre oui ça parle
d'amour de haine et c'est l'émoi des
peausseries de ça et sa corsa signature
encore une fois et je pense que
d assister à cet amour des deux
personnes et que vous avez dit au début
qui sont plus jeunes et malgré ça ils
pensent encore que tout peut arriver
c'est quelque chose de très beau me dire
que la faune sunnite et la sexualité et
l'amour sont liées à l'énergie et par
l'âge on accorde l espérance
ont regardé quoi ça ressemble
tu as encore postés à sabari chimiste
on a cru se maintenir
[Musique]
oh
hoya
savard a déplu
c'est très bien
présente depuis ce 15 août à côté
[Musique]
c lui a jamais dit
abbas
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
voilà je vous conseille ce crime alors
nous dit dans le film à un moment j'en
ai marre d'être belle
mais c'est les personnages les costards
qui me dit tu es belle j'ai dit la
beauté mais à cause d'eux que des
problèmes parce que il révèle là la pire
partie des gens je sais pas si c'est
vrai ça moi je pense que la beauté c'est
un cadeau qu'est la 8 e dan mais c'est
vrai que ça peut
provoquer des réactions des fois qu'ils
sont pas les bonnes alors été embarquée
dans ce film après votre divorce donc
après 18 ans et deux enfants avec
vincent cassel oui j'étais complètement
perdu tout ce que j'avais construit
avait volé en éclats du jour au
lendemain après une réaction de presque
20 ans je devais reconstruire ma vie
quand on fait un film comme ça on se
reconstruit c'est une oeuvre d'art à dix
ans quel amour pour moi c'est un moteur
que ce soit dans la relation que ce soit
avec les amis que ce soit surtout les
enfants et la famille je crois à l'amour
comme un moteur d'existence aujourd'hui
on va parler de votre situation maritale
parce que c'est une émission qui est
vraiment basée sur la discrétion s'est
cognée c'est très connu sera tout le
monde le sait rien de la main ils en
chient la règle on dirait un diabétique
à côté d'un gâteau ailleurs la mauvaise
non non ce qui m'a fait plaisir dans vos
dernières déclarations c'est que vous
parlez donc de l'homme de votre vie
actuellement vous dites que vous aimez
ces rites moi ça me touche beaucoup
parce que je commence à en avoir
quelques-unes et vous
parce que quand je lis qu'il rend sexy
c'est son vécu
sa grand-mère et tourner les choses
je disais que justement quand j'étais
jeune et moins attention à ça
aujourd'hui je vais je pense que énorme
qui a du vécu il est très charmant il ya
une phrase que j'adore c'est peut-être
pas destiné à votre homme actuelle en
tous les cas c'est une belle phrase à
travers les froissements du corps on
voit mieux l'âme
mais si
c'est bien bah disons qu'à peut-être que
c'est ce comment savoir ce qu'il ya
derrière au bout d'un moment c'est très
intéressant
j'aime bien si c'est vous moi j'aime
bien aussi le désir ne s'éteint pas en
vieillissant avec le temps le sexe
devient plus réfléchi mais le plaisir
est aussi plus fort
si je dis ça
c'est peut-être moi qui
n'aimais pas trop parler et si vous
parlez beaucoup de choses privées comme
ça trop pas
trop le chic de l'émission mais bon et à
l'époque tu tu nous avais dit que tu
étais ikhwan ouais c'est vrai à la
disant que j'ai amélioré mon qu'est ce
que ça veut dire en fait
ouais c'est à dire quelqu'un qui a une
qui bouge par passion un peu parce qu'on
vendra pas plus se laisser les langues
en fait c'est qu'elles ont été écrites
alliant airways s'est agacé tedj italien
après j'avais à l'époque je parlais
encore moins bien alors je parle pas
bien aujourd'hui qu'il faut parler mieux
à l'époque
ça fait deux ans que je viens pas bah
oui c'est pour ça qu'on est très heureux
de vous avoir
dit moi aussi c'est vous
quand sensualité et sexualité se mêle à
l'amour ça devient d'apothéose
qui ne cherchent pas l'amour et la
passion ensemble les problèmes justement
des fois c'est ça dans l'avion pouvoir
continuer à désirer et la personne qu'on
aime
non
tunis en a eu
le mans
éditions
télé
alors il ya un lift est sorti qui
s'appelle rencontres clandestines
écrit par guillaume balas cetto ou vous
raconter beaucoup de choses c'est aux
éditions de l'archipel j'étais dans un
moment de ma vie un peu particulier
dans ma vie privée et je commençais les
films de kusturica et on se rencontrer
pendant ces moments que je tournais les
films c'est long moment et voilà et on
se rencontre et je me suis dit si on va
au delà du fait que je suis comédienne
et toi écrivain d'un coup peut-être
qu'on peut faire une chose en résidence
change ses éditions de l'archipel hong
kong clandestine ya plein de trucs on
apprend des trucs incroyables
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu